city of henderson is approving a new
high-rise condo development soon
construction will begin on the pinnacle
residencies it's located inside of
mcdonald highlands joe moeller spoke to
the developer about the project
first residential high-rise development
in the city of henderson and with views
like this the builder says this
development will be unlike any other in
the valley a strip few in las vegas is
like an ocean view in california the
fast-growing city of henderson is now
going vertical every unit will have a
270 degree strip view the pinnacle
towers project recently got the green
light from the city developer jim reilly
says the towers will be inside the
mcdonald highlands community it's
actually 22 and 23 stories
respectively on the buildings it's 171
residences in the sky the development
announced an upscale restaurant called
noble heights that will be inside one of
the towers as for those concerned about
towers popping up on the bear hillside
exclusive listing agent kristen ruth
silverman says they are discreetly
placed in a canyon ironically you won't
really notice it until you're really
inside the gate she says this is
expanding the type of real estate
options in southern nevada for people
looking for a specific lifestyle it will
be fully serviced five-star luxury
modern indoor outdoor living she says
prices start at just over two million
dollars and hundreds of people have
placed reservations they plan to
advertise the buildings in other states
soon we really want to take this to
the residents of las vegas and henderson
first before we go out to california a
well-known brand will soon take over the
hospitality part of the project riley
expects the pinnacle towers to be
completed in 2025. it is designed to to
live like a resort residential community
while infrastructure work on the project
is set to start next month they expect
construction on the towers to start in
january reporting in henderson joe
muller live local now